it's nice to see you it is nice to be
seen I am so happy that I got to jump on
a plane and I get to sit here with you
again yeah thank you for doing that for
flying all the way here I imagine that
wonderful nauseous feeling of jet lag
that just overtakes your body as you
land and struggle with that you're very
sweet yeah I truly appreciate you and
the crew for taking the time to come
well we're excited to see you again
as your fans are what does it feel like
to sort of feel the love and feel the
warmth from everybody ah it's spamming
there was a reason that I chose here I
always had a really deep relationship
with the Irish I really do I have
there's a really great fun you know
genuine love for each other I think they
like a lot of the music and our humors
very similar as a Canadian so on it was
amazing for me I told my manager that I
wanted a chance to to dip my toes back
in the water after being gone for a
couple years and I said you know maybe
we can go to someone like Dublin and you
know maybe play a little club or uh or a
nice theater where I can just feel the
people and it can be this nice energy so
he called me a few months later herself
I got it we buck croak and I said great
you know Croke Park he says and I
thought to myself Park I thought about
like tea maybe people having some tea
under tree in a tree and it being this
family thing and then I found it it was
seventy thousand people and uh but you
know what I didn't care either way
all I could think was like that I
couldn't wait to be back I couldn't wait
to do what I love to do when I couldn't
wait to be surrounded by all that love
and joy and it's gonna be a magical I
missed it I really did I missed I missed
this part of it so the last time I saw
you was on set
yeah and your life changed within a
couple weeks after that was it a tough
decision to step away like you stepped
away from every yeah no no there's no
you know that there's no decision to be
made that's it that's uh there was no
decision yeah just do what you have to
do for the family yeah
your fans were where I always saw their
for you how much did that mean to you oh
I mean it was huge I think my wife and I
and our family I don't know that people
will ever understand that we know we're
not the only family that's gone through
hard things and the fact that we not
only did we know that there were people
that were sending us messages of love
that there were people in their churches
and synagogues and temples all over the
world praying for us that meant like I
thought so many times about how this
what I would say in this moment how I
would feel and I and I realized that I
just want it to be as positive as
possible mm-hmm you know I want other
other parents to know that there's
there's hope in it even when there's not
somehow it's gonna be okay and you know
I don't know mm-hmm and your family was
was so important in instrumental yeah
they left they left they my my sisters
took their their kids out of school both
they left their jobs they left
everything they came to be with us
mm-hmm they just saw us yeah perspective
this must have given you you know you
talk about when when we were on set of
music
we talked about your album and you had
made some major changes and you were
very focused on those new changes but
being away for these two years must give
you a whole new perspective than what
you had then the perspective came on the
first day on the first day the
perspective came on Halloween which was
the day that the day that we got the
diagnosis it all came in one snap my
whole life changed and my perspective on
life my philosophical idea of what it's
all about and what matters just in one
snap I changed and that's a good thing
because I'm thankful I'm thankful for
the for the Grace and thankful for the
then the faith I'm thankful for all that
I feel deeply connected to people all
over I really do I mean coming back like
this because people can say it isn't a
comeback but men I was gone and I didn't
know if I would ever ever thought I was
going to be my next question because did
you know how long you were going to be I
figured it I wouldn't I really did I
figured that I thought you were done and
not coming back listen it became so
clear that none of it was very important
you know and and what had become
important to me in many for many years
started was the wrong thing
you know I think I started to worry more
about you know hanging on to something
and and how many records and and you
know what do you mean that's not sold
out or and mmm everything from people
you know listen I I said to a friend the
other day I said they were talking about
their their Instagram and I just said I
god bless you I'm happy that it brings
you joy but I I don't give I don't want
to know and I just said love not likes
love not likes like
that's just it listen when you deal with
a health thing it doesn't matter if it's
your own or and and we all will every
single person watching berries yeah then
it gets so clear and you know and I'm in
your okay I I wish that we never my boy
never had to go through all the things
that he had to go through or that my
wife or our family or friends but yeah
but the good perspective yeah the
perspective that I live with every day
is a good thing you were always a
grounded man since the day that I met
you the very first time but you seemed
so much more now and more present that
I've never seen before
thank you I'm happy incredible I'm happy
you know yeah I'm happy because none of
it none of it listen it's nice it's just
there's what's important and then
there's everything else that's what when
it gets that simple you you know one of
the things that it really allows you to
do is really enjoy enjoy the
relationships enjoy the moment and the
laughter and and the romance and all of
the things knowing I took it into making
a record and that was me and David
Foster you know rekindle our romance
well that's that's we need to talk about
right over there do you know people
don't know this but I know there's news
above Kathryn yes but you're his first
love people don't know that I was almost
as fifth right so how do you feel the
fact that you don't it's never going to
happen now gypped are you going to sing
it the way I know if you never asked me
but I would listen I love that man so
much that I have only always wanted to
be just like a foster child I know wait
though I'm so glad I got to use that
yeah you did you finally threw that in
there I like it so what did Lou say when
you said you wanted to get back at it
because I'm sure that was a discussion
that you had with her did she want you
to come back before now or was she
waiting for you to say when
were ready I think she was waiting for I
think she was working member the truth
is she she had decided that she wanted
to come back way before me yeah way
before me she had she had caught
contractually a movie they she continued
that she couldn't leave them hanging
they had filmed a big chunk of the movie
and she knew that she wouldn't do that
to them and so as soon as we you know
things started to turn well and we knew
that we were okay and that no was good
she went back and she did a she had to
do a press conference about the movie
and we knew that they were gonna ask
questions and so she sort of handled
that for me because I couldn't have done
it not at that point I you weren't ready
no I didn't I mean
I'd like I said I believe at that point
I wasn't sure that I would ever be ready
your main job is watching the family
that's all I cared about I mean I just
didn't get I mean honestly people
couldn't you know God my listen my
manager my record company they showed me
who I they are who I thought they were
you know they no one ever brought a word
up to me about working or or contracts
or shows booked never never a word I
mean not one email message
no one alluding to you know hey you know
are you feeling like you nothing every
every single day was a message from the
president of my record company saying I
love you thinking about you praying for
you my manager saying you know you know
I'm with Bryan Adams on the road here at
Jann Arden and and you know they just
send their love and nothing never a I
never felt a an iota of pressure and
that you know as I sit here now and I'm
about to come back and I'm about to play
these stadiums and you know it's a
there's a great sense of
of team and family and like we're doing
this this isn't me
coming back it's us coming back you know
we built we built this thing and it's
gonna be a blast for us too I'll be able
to celebrate it together and actually be
in the moment enough to celebrate